you have to pre-qualify now yeah you
know and one thing I pre-qualify with is
money
you know because if you go off take a
piss if Sterling Cooper goes to take a
piss and we're at a restaurant the first
thing I do is look at the girl he's with
and say how the [__] did you get started
Cooper first thing like that's just how
we run our offense you know in regards
to money same thing like I don't I don't
want to think that I'm going to pick up
every Bill the biggest game that we play
between the five of us that hang out is
who can act like they're going to take a
piss and pay the bill behind everybody's
back gotcha [__] like that's I
literally do it all the time I'll go to
do it and somebody would have already
done it 30 minutes ago or vice versa
and like that's the kind of stuff you
want to do with your boys